[Music]
hello
[Music]
can you hear me
hello
gotta see if this is working first i
think so
hello
you can hear me excellent
excellent
[Music]
welcome
everybody
let's kiss
that's a good idea
i don't know why i'm here i know [ __ ]
all about the lore dude
i don't feel like anybody really knows
what's going on here
you guys really think you know what's
going on
[Music]
as some stuff i think
so hello celeste
hello everybody
i have not streamed in a while it feels
like forever it's been almost a month
since i've uh
since i've streamed
so i gotta remember how to do this
we'll get into it man
but welcome appreciate you being here
we're just gonna talk today that's
that's pretty much all we're gonna do
and then obviously you know
we're gonna look at stuff
just discuss things if if you guys are
into that if that sounds good to you
i know nothing about the lord but i've
beaten the game two times
[Music]
i don't i i don't know how many times
i've beaten the game now
it's uh
a lot
[Music]
am i here early we just started handgun
so welcome man
welcome welcome welcome good to have you
here the only lore i know is what you've
posted
[Music]
yeah the the lore in this game is very
very complicated
also we're using hacks
which is why
oh there we go
we're using hacks this is why we're
floating around like this
you make everything a little bit more
interesting
we can go and look at anything which is
pretty cool
then we can go back to this
don't learn about dark souls 1
they're they're actually learning things
about dark souls 1 all the time
um another thing this character
right here is max level
99 overall in everything
we also have
every item in the game
every sword at everything we have
so if we ever like want to look at an
item description we can just go in and
do that like right away
which is pretty cool and then like i
just showed we got the free cam mod
so we can look around at stuff or look a
lot closer at things as well
which i think could help with
discussions things like that
so yeah
altus plateau since you're on next-gen
it should be beautiful make it morning
watch the sunrise and all the fog go
away it's amazing
i've seen that man that that happens
every time you go there for the first
time i believe
and then we have every side of grace
unlocked without going to any of them
actually this is a totally like new
character so
like i i think if i went into radon
right now he would just be standing
there actually
well if it isn't my favorite tuber
yep there he is um
thank you teflon i appreciate the three
months man thank you
welcome back
yeah he's just standing there like a g
and then we can use free cam to look a
bit closer
there he is boys
why is he like vibrating you see that
anyway yeah there's a lot of stuff we
can do with these mods and stuff so
that'll be really cool
but thank you again teflon
elden ring
dating simulator
radon dating simulator
look guys we're on a date
what's up leonard
can we look at the door above the elden
beast
um i mean we can go in there actually
i gave him a kiss
i think it'll pop up when i run forward
yep there we go
this is so epic
there we go
yeah who wouldn't want to go on a date
with radon
wow that really just missed huh
okay
yeah share any theory you guys got man
i'm here to listen
here to listen and discuss
that's pretty good damage
damn
excellent
i think i actually have to beat him to
get out of here now or i could just quit
out actually i didn't think of that
there we go
hold on i gotta remember how to stream
dude i i haven't done this in like a
month and i do not remember how to do
this
elden rings unknowable mythos is just
weird considering what we know about
gwen in the kindling of the first plane
we barely know why anyone in elden ring
did anything
i mean
i don't think we know definitively on
anything in elden ring which which is
where my frustration comes from
[Music]
i don't know if that's the case with
everybody but i just i feel like
everything in this game we don't know
like a hundred percent positive on you
know
like we can make theories and stuff but
other than that
we don't know anything
or it feels that way
you have any any idea what the red spear
in america could be
i was talking with uh retro who's in our
discord about that red spear and
he has a theory that
it was
maliketh
who speared him with that that red
yeah it's just like a red spear
panchavari yes sir
no problem
but yeah
he had a theory that it could have been
malacath which
makes sense in some ways and makes no
sense in others
okay i'm not going to kiss vary what is
this yeah we don't need that
what if morga in the opening credits
stabbed radon
ratagon instead of radon
the size matches radon could be wearing
armor fashion from his father
hmm
that's interesting i haven't thought of
that
i haven't thought of radon
because like my theory on radon is that
he was
smaller and then he grew bigger
which goes with the horse thing you know
like
he was smaller when he had his rehorse
and then he got bigger but he didn't
want to not have his horse anymore so he
just didn't care
and
studied gravity magic for that reason
you know what i mean
oh man we already got bots
sick
goodbye
they go
what happened with demon souls
dude
i
have have you guys played demon souls
have you have you guys actually played
that game
i believe there are seven six endings
six or
seven believe we know of every ending
now
yes
do you guys like demon souls
because i mean after playing all the
other games
and then going back to demon souls even
with the remaster it looks absolutely
beautiful
but um
i'm having a hard time playing that game
i really am like i don't
enjoy the
it's it's very
hard to play
even though i've heard a lot of people
say it's like the easiest souls game and
i i disagree with that completely
dead goat
yeah it feels like it you know all of
the things that are in it are just not
quite right i i don't know and obviously
it was the first one so
i don't know i really didn't
did not enjoy it very much which is why
i stopped streaming it i was not having
a good time with it not gonna lie
armored spider i don't yeah i don't i'm
not a big fan of the boss fights in it i
think i'm like halfway done with it
right now um
but i'm not sure
how does lore hunting work you guys ask
me stuff and we go and look at those
things so the character that i'm playing
on has every item in the game we can
read every item description we can
i'm using this free cam mod to look at
characters closer like
i'm just kind of vibing with chat that's
how this works
uh are you gonna play dark souls 2 or
skip it to play dark souls 3
i do want to stream a bit more
because i haven't streamed in like a
month
um
we could play dark souls 2 yeah
yeah it's not that i think demon souls
is bad it's just like the way it's set
up i'm not a huge fan of
holly maiden
whoa has there always been that many
boats out there
what the heck
it seems like more boats than i've seen
out there before
what happened to godfrey's axe what does
it look like what's wrong with it
wait hold on i could fly over there
no
it's a lot of shipwrecks out here
hmm
interesting
do we know where these came from like
why are these here
i don't think i've read anything about
shipwrecks
in this game before
interesting
yo what's up ester how are you good to
see you
on why godfrey's so big
i mean he's just a freaking beast i
would assume yeah
is he even that big
i'm trying to read everybody
spirit gold and his axe in the whole
form
does his axe change
i guess we can go see
uh if i go in there like this
then it will just eat me into the gideon
fight which i doubt we want to do
um
okay hopefully the tree isn't burning
when i'm here
thank you seki too appreciate it
uh if you can turn off the ghost loretta
at the carrion manor
uh is the glidstone on your staff still
glidstone or is it unalloyed gold
we can look at that too
i should be able to write torrent hello
hacks
we gotta use our hacks i thought i
already did this i guess not
other scripts
uh
right anywhere there we go
sick
is gold mask an albastar lord he does
kind of look like he's made of stone
doesn't he
i don't think so though
the type of skin he has really does
kind of look like that though
a good theory
hmm
yeah there's usually a usually a chip in
this right in his
axe he doesn't have surash either no
suraj here
why does godfrey kill suraj to
unleash his warrior side of himself
saraj is meant to calm him down
so he just rips him off and goes crazy
turns into horror lou although he's not
horolu here and he doesn't have suraj
look at his size
i mean yeah he's tall
but he's a god right well he's not a god
he's uh
i don't know just a freaking stud man
you think he could be like a giant or
something
no i don't know how to take helmets off
i'm still learning how to do this stuff
uh is renal or in renal it says that
ronnie found her deep in the woods
where in the woods in the deep woods uh
i would assume larenia lakes because
that's kind of where she's located
like in the woods there
yeah i think he's just big like i don't
think it's really anything
like that
like he's a giant or anything
maybe we we need to learn more about the
badlands and honestly we just don't know
anything which sucks
oh i can't leave
dude
hmm
without time
yeah ratagan is definitely shorter than
godfrey
ratagan's pre i think he's about the
size of melania
isn't the badlands caled no
it is not
apparently the badlands are outside of
the lands between like
somewhere
what is the red border behind him
red border
hold on
this oh gosh
okay so the theory i wanted to talk to
you guys today about i think might stir
some real freaking conversation man
i don't see a red border
i just see gold
i don't know if you guys are ready for
this theory though i think it'll freak
you out
what up buddy
tell us ah do i just wait to make it
into a video and then have you guys
discuss it there
because i i really want to tell this but
i think it'll just make people mad
all right promise me you guys won't get
mad
we should probably get into this
this is a big one like really really
really big
[ __ ] off the ledge
yes ma'am
oh well
it is part of lore hunting this is true
all right you guys are all promising me
this
oh this this is bad man
you guys gonna be like
huh
excuse me
okay i think this will trigger the
cutscene but he won't attack us
yeah it does
okay
you guys ready for this he's gonna
wander around
there we go
i have a theory that that is not mikala
clear your mind and accept what i said
there
the only thing we're going off for him
to be mikala is because moog says
that
dearest mikala
you must abide alone a while or whatever
i don't know who this is
i don't know
but i don't think it's mickela
and what i think moog is talking to
is his blood
not the body form
does that make sense
i think he's
whatever this person is in here
is a vessel
for mikola's blood
in whatever moog is trying to do
so
he just refers to him as mikala because
it's full of nicolas blood
and i do think that mikola
is in the capital
where we just were
which is what reminded me of this
and i have a theory
that
who i'm about to show you i think is i
think is mikla
why would michela need a vessel he
doesn't moog does
i think i see him in here
so hold on
like this is a big one it like can you
guys imagine if i made a video called
this isn't mikala
with the thumbnail pointing to the to
the cocoon like people be like excuse me
no
that would just get gassed up very
quickly
oh let me beat him real quick
i don't think he kidnapped the wrong kid
he got what he needed which was the
blood
uh
but not a lot else
everyone talks about how bleed is opie
can we talk about
frost
okay so what did you smoke
have you guys not noticed this thing up
here
i know if you look at the intro i don't
think
who's in the cocoon is mikala
i think this is mykolo
or it's one of mikala's bodies
which goes into more of what i
am theorizing is that mycola can take
many different types of bodies
it's close to the perfumer robes but not
quite it's not the perfumer
tr i've been i've been theorizing on
this for like two weeks now
the item here is the golden order
principal
which is how you learn
that america is ratagon
or ratagon is america
i think this is one of mikala's bodies
and he can do this because he's been
spreading his form throughout the haley
tree
and now people are taking off branches
of him
and making him
into it's really hard to explain which
is why i have not made a video on this
yet
yeah it's so hard to pass like to to
convince people of this
but this is the golden order principle
it's how you learn you you learn the
incantations or the yeah the
incantations
to then find out that ratagon is america
but i think this is this is mykola
it's in
or near the bed's queen champ or yeah
the queen's bed chamber
this looks like a [ __ ] crib to me
this
hanging like why is this here
like what is this who is this it's just
like this hanging
it looks like a crib to me
you know
and it's near america's bedroom it's
right over here
right across the way it's america's
bedroom
with this guy waiting right here
which
i think
mikala
potentially could have been stabbed by
this guy
but he's in like
several different places
so
if you guys look at the intro
um is there a way i can look that up let
me see
hold on
pass it over okay calm down people
calm down um
i guess if i just put in mogu i bet it
would come up
uh
of course not moog intro
do you guys not see that he has the
cocoon on his back
right here
oh god i haven't been on reddit in three
months i'm not gonna cap
the cocoon's right here
it's on his back he's carrying it it's
dripping blood out of it
who is this
the black knives are potentially women
it it does suggest that most of them are
women but it doesn't necessarily mean
that all of them are it's
it's tough
it slips a finger in your booty okay
but i think a lot of people miss that
moog is carrying the cocoon here on his
back but
whoever this is not inside of it
and
okay so let's look at this body right
here like we're all suggesting that this
is mykolo right
this is mikala look at the size here
like his like much smaller than mogu's
right much much much smaller than moog
and then
we go back to the cocoon
whoever is in there is
much
much larger than moog
look at that arm that his arm is as tall
as him
you know
so i don't think
i don't i i i'm having a hard time
believing that this is mykla
i wish i could put a light in here
yeah it could potentially be growing
america's tits
mo can you shut up please
also that's another really good point
this body here
we're gonna have to go beat up moe or
morgot
you guys cool with that if i go be beat
up morgot
very
very similar
uh body type to a um to an almond
i'm not kissing mogu
ah [ __ ] we burned it down
hold on
look at the intro at morgot versus radon
they seem to be the same size and that
is not the case
yeah radon grew we're not talking about
radon though
that's suggested to be like uh radon has
giant genetics
i don't know why i went here
uh
i have to go here again this is like the
only place you can go to without it just
automatically burning down the tree
[Music]
yep level three
734 by the way
in the dlc you find out mickela is you
that is actually an insanely
good theory
an insanely good theory
wouldn't mow know that though maybe he
doesn't because a part of this theory as
well is that moog is absolutely bonkers
insane
which i think we can all can we all
agree that that moog is
out of his out of his mind
most of the time
all the time
i think mo is the craziest dude in this
in this entire game
melania does help you out with more guy
and i'm very surprised how many people
miss that
i already have that
who were the crucible knights loyal to
that's a i saw that on twitter
i think they do that all the time where
they just randomly talk about stuff so i
don't think um
yeah you can summon her right here
um i don't think that really has to do
with much
i'm gonna watch this cut scene i really
like this one
graceless tarnished
okay honestly everyone in this game is
bonkers that's very true what is thy
business with these thrones
yes a lot of people miss that summon so
many
how do the cats stop saying stuff like
that or i'm gonna ban you
does he even mention godwin here
i haven't even thought of that
luna princess ronnie
willful traitors
oh maybe it's because godwin's not a
traitor so he doesn't say it
thy kind
wait whose throne is it
whose throne is it that isn't glowing
the normal throne that's there
pillagers
emboldened by the flame of ambition it's
not godfreys
have it read upon my meager grave
it
is it raticons
i don't think so lost of all kings yeah
we became elden lord and we sit there so
it has to be the elden lord which is
ratagon okay i was thinking potentially
that it could be
godwins
for a second
stop walking around we need to look at
your body
i don't like how dark it is hold on
there we go
look at that it's changed the time of
day
oh well no one's gonna be
this so
freaking powerful
what is this
oh my god that is strong
how much damage does that do
stained by my curse
such shelling i cannot bear
there isn't this movie part in this
shall not be forgiven yep
that's pretty cool
okay
who's god of roy i couldn't even begin
to tell you
okay so this body right here boys
this is why we did this
why is it dark again
look at this body
okay
in all of its glory
kind of cut out like a giant
not gonna cap on that i don't know where
that comes from
kind of gray
stoney
kinda sorta
you know
eyes gouged out little spots on the head
things like that
and then
we go back over her oh no it's not gonna
let me move until i go up here
yeah it's too small but we're looking at
the details
the details people
it it looks just like the body in the
cocoon
it is like
very closely identical to the one in the
cocoon
oh god i haven't even met nicola or
melania in here yet
it like it is identical to the body in
here
get out of the way moke
nerd
look right here
look do those those spots are exactly
the same
exactly the same
gouged out eyes spot on the forehead
i'm like right up in his crotch
ew
uh
like spotty
it is exactly the same but this is a
bigger model
is that a snake ring
fbi open up
i think this is an omen vessel
and we've seen you know like uh
morgot
can make many different versions
versions of himself all over like he
made himself a bargain
which
he technically dies there but that's
just like a
clone version of himself like kind of
like a summon of himself over there
yes the covetous serpent ring
this theory holds no water i don't know
how you can say that i really don't
but people will that's why i was saying
like
doesn't uh godwin's body have uh rings
on it as well
oh god
see this is why i don't want to make a
video on it because people are just
gonna be like me
me
dang
hey it's trey thanks man
thank you for the membership i
appreciate you very much
this game is so big there's no way to
prove or discredit this theory
proof
through
okay but he has like rings right
yeah right there
on his arm
thing
it's like a bracelet not a ring
hmm
i think there's one on the other arm too
yep
i don't know what that is though
yeah it's like a bracelet
we don't know of godwin's great roon yet
no
i don't know how he'd get one
where are you we're in the deep root
depths
underground
right here
below the capitol
maybe there's shackles
well the uh
mogan
market shackle are not
they don't look like that
if we're talking like specific shackles
but he's not an almond as well which is
what they're made for
we also have every item in the game so
you guys like you got an item we want to
look up
let me know
his body confuses me too because i see a
fish here right
like right here i see a fish
like kind of a mermaid fin type of deal
going on here
and then this is like a cloth
it's like half-assed effort and like
hiding it what is in here
i thought that was a face for a second i
was gonna freak out
he's becoming a it doesn't look like a
dragon though
but that that would make sense to his
character though
it just doesn't look like one to me
is there anything in here
i mean could there be a fish dragon
yeah there's like nothing in here
i don't think
no
what if he sunk the ships
so he's a mermaid
and he's been
bonking people out of the sea
that's interesting
could be
you guys think this is poop
never mind
it looks like uh the bottom of a porta
potty
ah okay that scared me
he shed skin from the god devouring
serpent the theory that he was eaten by
the snake
right
i had that theory i actually made a
video on it and people like absolutely
bash that theory completely
he's a fish man
yeah sea dragon
yeah like a sea dragon
yeah
we just
we really don't know anything about
godwin
he would answer so many questions
but yeah just to go back to
before
you guys like even if you're like this
theory holds no ground you cannot deny
that mo or the body that's in this
cocoon whether it's michelle or not
looks exactly like the body of morgot
when he isn't a uh
when we kill him
dude his middle finger is a horn
oh he takes a wink at you gross
does mo got a ring
let us look
he's flipping you guys off
that's a part of his clothing yeah it is
it's not a bracelet
he has a horn going into his eye
that's kind of cool
yo have you guys seen what eg looks like
why did america downgrade to ratagon
wasn't it because she had to or
something
he's definitely got a sore throat
you guys ready for this
there's his eyes
wait i can zoom out like this
wait
increase the fob
beautiful
yeah
he uh he's a giant i'll tell you that
he's a giant
he is nasty looking man
it's disgusting
stealth
self-cis
yes self-cest
the basis of mykla having multiple
bodies is because i
is because i think he
mikala is the haleg tree
which i think everybody knows this right
so everybody sees this face in the spite
right
maybe a lot of people have missed this
i think mykola is the haley tree his
blood is all within it and people are
taking out branches of it and putting it
inside of vessels like the body we find
in the cocoon and trying to grow
a new empyrean demigod within this
[ __ ] cocoon
because i i'm pretty sure most people
see
like do you guys see the face
there's a body in the tree right there
which right here as well
it would be the perfect spot
for
like
the tree is pregnant with something
right so this would be the stomach which
was the cocoon
which
i don't know if a ton of people have
noticed this either
but the cocoon is resting on a pelvic
bone
which would be right where like a
pregnant
stomach would be
right here
on a pelvic bone so he didn't just rip
out the cocoon he ripped out like a
[ __ ]
we we just don't know that's what's so
hard about this
we don't know for sure
it's like he's making almonds
using michela's blood
which is how i think there are multiple
bodies
the growling's moog
he's feeling here
what was melania doing melania's blind
he can't see he doesn't really know
what's there or not
you know
she straight up doesn't have eyes
he's just such a skilled swordsman that
she can fight against us in that fight
uh let me go back like we can look at a
really good look at her eyes like she
she cannot see anything
that's what i'm thinking he took he took
mikala's like pelvic bone and is using
it to make a new imperium for his outer
god
where is she there she is
like you guys think she can see because
i don't
no shot
can we see the top branches of the two
trees what do you mean
we're bots when are they gonna fix this
this bot problem
that hairline though that is a receding
ass hairline
but there's no shots she can see
anything so i think
i think
she
knows where she is
but she doesn't know
where mickel is he's at least not
answering her she's
so she just stays
you go into her head oh i can go
anywhere
is she wearing a uh
headband
is that
there you go
we're inside of her head
we got a mouth
no eyeballs
what's your take on saint trina
i think one of mykola's bodies is saint
trina
where was she when moe took the egg the
timeline on that is confusing
because
it it would make the most sense if she
were
fighting radon
and then bogue just
press one in chat if we need dlc
better see a bunch of ones man
we we need dlc to answer these questions
man we really need more info we just
don't have it right now
we just don't
sucks
yeah a lot of ones my god
so i think my theory holds a lot of
ground it will just be very
controversial
very
if i made that into a video though i
think that has the potential to get a
million views
because people be like what
are you talking about
huh
moog literally says that he's mickela
bro it's like maybe he's talking to the
blood not the body
can i hit her here
did she fall down
her body went lower interesting
let's look up in here a bit more
what's going on in here
these kind of look bony right here
a little bit
these branches
kinda sorta
whoa there's a hole
the heck
the water stopped
wait is this hole on the other side
yeah the face is definitely in the tree
was that just like lazy clipping by the
dubs or does this mean anything
where did melania and radon fight again
where you fight radon in the caled wilds
yeah the face is right here
nose mouth
eyes
it's definitely made out of like
bark tree
tree bark
they're fighting for the great runes
is it
what is this
is it confirmed
that
the demigods all fought for and obtained
the great runes after the shattering or
were they given the great runes before
the shattering
it's unclear right
like the way they word it and what
happens is weird
they fought for them
did they though
or where they f like they had them and
then they fought for them yes
just to get more of them
you know what i'm saying
melania says america gave it to them to
decide for themselves what to do with it
do you remember where it says that so
that we can read it or is there dialogue
of that
because i'm like 90
percent sure that they were given them
before the elden ring was shattered and
then all the demigods fought for the
great runes that they already had
because trying to remember where every
item description is is like impossible
dialogue in one of the churches
it's uh
which church
because we can go there and get uh
melanoma immediately after i do the gate
front which i still need to do
let's do that really quick
see that that was my initial thought was
that when the elden ring was shattered
the runes literally split and were i
don't know flung around all over the
place and then the demigods got them
but i don't think that's the case
it's not the third church
i have to do this real quick
i'm i'm
99 sure that melana is a fragment of
america
i'm like 99 sure that melania is just a
fragment of america to help us with
their overall plan
which i made a video about a week ago
which you guys should all go watch
greetings
traveller
from beyond the fog
hello i am melaner
i
offer you an accord i love honda accords
such a great car
have you heard of the finger maidens uh
i made one like that i made a destin
death video about three months ago lewis
into strength which i should do an
updated video on
then it's settled
summon me by grace
ah torrent treat him with so here here's
my theory tell me if you agree on it or
not of of how the elden ring runes were
given out
let me go into a pretty spot
this will be
quite the
let me know if you agree on this
the
so i doubt
that
the greater will would have just let
america shatter the elder ring
right or at least like she needed to do
something before that would work right
so
she gave them out to her children
and said like here's your like you have
this great room this great room this
great room like use it for you know
whatever
and then she shattered it
so it was already weakened but the
grader will like kind of let her like we
don't know this so that's just my theory
kind of let her be like okay that makes
sense like yeah your kids are devout
golden order followers obviously right
even though we know they're not
um gave that to them
and then she shattered it
and then all of her kids were like well
[ __ ] and then they all did their own
thing fighting for more
can you see what i'm do you see what i'm
saying there
and then the shattering war was like
radon has his melania has his or like as
an example and they
they fight for it they want the other
ones as well like it just starts an
all-out like war let's go
why give one to morgotten moog
they fought for it and obtained it
during the war
right
because i doubt she could give it to
them
so maybe there were some of them that
did obtain it
like my theory is godric didn't just get
a great rune i think it was godwin's
great rune and then godric got it from
godwin does that make sense
which makes me think all of them were
pillaged as well augusto that's why it's
so unclear
she shattered the elden ring so godwin
could kill the urgery that's a part of
it
i think godwin is killing the erd tree
just by existing
the soulless demigods were the original
holders
the ones in the um mausoleums
there was a throne for godric but not
godwin
well
so the knight of black knives happened a
long time
before the shattering right
like a very long time
all the children of the golden lineage
has anchor runes so that might have been
gifted them
anchor runes
god of freud didn't get a throne i think
god of roy is a alternate dimension
version of godric
is godric a true member of the golden
lineage
therefore
son of america and god pre or is he the
son of godwin
i think he's the son of godwin but every
time i say that people like [ __ ] on it
every time i've mentioned that in a
video they're like no
he's just
i don't know
they say something that isn't that makes
no sense to me
that's the other part
godfrey could just be some lazy ass
addition to have another boss
america gifting the runes is the outer
wall battlegrounds all right thank you
that's where we're going
right here right
yup
i know exactly where everything is i'm
the lore guy i'm just kidding
i have played this game so [ __ ] much
since february it's actually insane
let's listen to this dialogue though we
gotta really analyze this one
we gotta go to the [ __ ] round table
guys
forgive me
to detect yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
whereas there is but i can take a
gathering place
no
i have to very well
come on let's go
let me touch your hand
oh excuse me
hey now we go
[Music]
thank you metal
how are you
[Music]
uh
dude what do you want
hello again
she's gonna leave allow me a moment
to converse with you wait what is this
you are unable to enter the earth tree
why are we doing this here prevented by
the mantle of bob's what the thorns are
impenetrable
a husk of the ur trees being
that spurns all that exists without
the only way to stand before the elden
ring hax tuxedo the elder lord
is to pass the thorns
my purpose
serves to aid in that very act okay yeah
give me the rolled medallion
yeah thank you appreciate it i already
have it
here we go okay this is the one we need
to listen to
so pay attention
spoken echoes linger here
words of queen america
who vanished long ago
if you wish
i will share them with you please
in america's own words
hear me
demigods
my children beloved
make of thyselves
that which he desire
be it a lord
be it a god
but should he fail to become ought at
all
you will be forsaken
a amounting only to sacrifices
dog
you ever wish they'd just talk like a
normal human being
i wish to journey with you once more
to the flame of ruin
far above the clouds that's so vague on
the snowy mountain tops off the giants
then
i can set the earth tree aflame
thy guide you
down the path i guide you to becoming
elden lord
okay
that
did not answer my questions
read more got mogs
there
okay
wait they're remembrance or they're
great runes
do i even have them
have every i have lots of items
there we go okay godricks
this great rune is known as the anchor
ring found in the center of the elden
ring that okay the first of the demigods
were the elden ring god
the first demigods were
the elden lord godfrey and his offspring
the golden lineage so that just
it's the anchor great rune it's the one
in the middle it holds all of it
together
that's all that means right
okay
reichard reichard was amongst the
children of branalla and radagon who
became demigod's stepchildren after
ratagan's union with queen america
obviously but reichardt fed himself to
the blasphemous serpent great roon and
all okay he's a stupid idiot radon was
amongst the children of ronaldo and
ratagan who became demigod children step
children brought a gun union with queen
america blah blah blah great rune burns
to resist the encroachment of scarlet
rot
yada yada
another anchor ring that houses the base
and proves two things that the omen king
was born of the golden lineage we
already knew that and that he was indeed
the lord of lando
okay
bear
have we ever thought that if somebody
was given a great rune or they obtained
it
could they even hold it
have we even
fathomed that thought
like
who's to say that anybody can hold a
great rune
like and then it's telling us here that
morgot was the only one that could hold
a this great room
mugs
okay
it's blessing grants a blessing of blood
to summon phantoms okay moog and morgot
are twin brothers and their great rune
runes are naturally similar but moog's
rune is soaked in a cursed blood from
his devout love for the wretched mire
that he was born into far below the
earth
what does that even mean dog
soaked in a cursed blood from his devout
love for the wretched mire
this makes me look so dumb but you all
do this too
don't you
you do it
you do these things when you're looking
up lore
a stretch of swampy or boggy ground
a situation or state of difficulty
distress or embarrassment from which it
had to eradicate oneself extricate
oneself
pause it become stuck in mud
okay
without love for the
just the sewers that's fine we already
knew that this means the sewers are the
swamp right
can you hold a great rune or does it go
inside you you can't hold it like in
your hand
all of the golden lineage get anchor
runes so this means moog morgot were
gifted their great rooms
is it saying that though
why is it called a shard bearer though
does it mean that it was broken into
shards or just removing them without
shattering it is considered a shard
you see what i'm saying
maybe i'm just overthinking it
this this is the the the way they
explain things makes it so confusing
the golden lineage children get anchor
roots
yes
they do
they're like the center
what does moog win
i feel like it has something to do with
the godwin
i do
this is why i like having these
discussions because we're all just
confused
ronald isn't a shard bearer we get a we
get a rune from her
the unborn one right
great rune of the unborn
amber egg clutched by ranala queen of
the full moon great rune of the unborn
of unborn demigods
reflects those who have been born anew
children born anew by ronald are all
frail and short-lived imperfect means
each and all
eldon ring confesses you sometimes it's
too vague to answer and you have to let
it go sometimes
i know
it's kind of my job to figure this stuff
out though so i'm trying
could that be mykolos
also this rune looks just like this one
just like melania's this one
and this one
okay hold on so they're saying that
morgot and moog's runes are
naturally similar
the this one and this one are very
similar
because they're also twins
melania
and mykola
but it doesn't say that this one's
mikola
that's very interesting
but this one and this one are also
similar
were reichard and
radon twins
kinda
it was a gift from radagon
how did he get it though
yeah not confirmed twins i know they're
brothers but i it's not confirmed
that they're twins obviously
the rune of the unborn wasn't nicolas
supposed to be a child forever i mean
that's his affliction is that he's
eternally a child
ratagon is micklem
hmm
because i mean we learn from ronnie that
you can just eat it
you can just eat it right
and be like nah i don't want it
where did she discard it
is it the moon
wait
okay no moon right now
her dark moon wait i have that spell
god damn that sounds insane
i love hacks
oh read it duh
legendary sorcery symbolic of the aryan
queen
uses the caster as a vessel to incarnate
a solid a cold dark moon then sends it
floating towards foes
the dark moon dispels all sorcery that
touches it and temporarily temporarily
reduces magic damage
negation for those it strikes
the moon was encountered
by a young ronnie
led by the hand of her mother rinala
what she
beheld was cold dark and viled in
speak normal
[ __ ]
okay i'm also dyslexic so i have to read
things more than once to
understand it
thank you metal for getting rid of the
bots we've had a lot of bots today i
don't know what's up with that
this moon was encountered by a young
ronnie
led by the hand of her mother ranala so
ranala showed her this moon
what she beheld was cold dark and viled
what is that word
supernatural
mystical
phenomenon got it so
nothing that makes sense
another way to say mystery we're saying
mystery mystery
one of a [ __ ]
look at her body
why are these here oh yeah i have the
rolled medallion
i love that i can ride torrent anywhere
so this is where ronnie's two fingers
would be
where everyone else's two fingers are
not here
i'm 99 sure that until we beat radon
her two fingers are in space
agree or disagree
well her body's dead yes
be dead as hell
why do you think there are two moons
on the moonlight altar because there are
literally two moons
so there's her um
curse mark
on her back
i
i would be thinking a better signal to
the greater will yes
seems like these help as well
excellent
i don't think they're the same braces as
godwin are they
i was thinking that too but they're
definitely not the same
this one fell off on her arm we get a
better look at this one
so it has these like looping like kind
of braided pattern on it with the
it looks like red type rubies
in it
and let's go back to godwin
hi jm17
[Music]
oh god i hate his face okay yeah that's
not
not exactly
love a crispy ronnie
absolutely
not seeing a comparison there definitely
different
definitely different what is this thing
on his
what is this
right here
is that an arm
this hair
oh i see i see
look how it wraps here as well
so this is his hair as well
so his hair is just frust
just so gross
yeah just like everything else in here
okay excellent excellent
why the fishtail we were saying earlier
that maybe he's becoming like a fish
dragon
but we don't know because they don't
tell us
anything
tell me stuff
i need to know
yeah they're definitely not the same
yeah like a mermaid yeah
but he's also like a mermaid dragon
because he was like with the dragons
in his lore
befriended four to sacks
bless me
hi glenn how are you more bots
more bots
thank you metal metal is on it i love it
thank you
why are we getting so many bots
yeah i thought that was hilarious mr
cocoa butter
the the video i made put out yesterday
is one of my favorite videos i made i
think it's
i think it's great
which i don't usually say for
most of my videos i think later like
[Music]
i really like that one
adult bots targeting virgins
true can we look at the dragon we would
have to do the entire quest line
to do that because there's no way for us
to just go in there
we could i mean we can do the quest
lines really really quickly
did we do that i don't think it'll tell
us very much to just look at fortisacks
though
because we don't have to walk anywhere
we can just
go
could be four to six
same thing
those orange
rocks at the top of the towers look like
the meteor stuff in places like falling
star beasts yes
i mean we i think that's just because
the greater will and the two fingers are
from another world like they're from
space so they have something to do with
those rocks
for sure
oh god
oh god look at that guys
look at that great animation
what happened here
sorry
what is this
it's like a bunch of blocks
i'm looking right at it it usually when
the camera is like off like this it'll
look like that what is happening
hello i've never seen that before
that's a mausoleum
hello i'm looking right at it oh [ __ ]
okay we're good
what if i go away come back
that's a bit that's that's that's a
little weird okay where do we go now
what should we do
do i really want to do the entire fiat
quest line
let's see how fast we can do it
wish we got more characters like
oh i like alexander yeah
malketh and morgoth are quite
sympathetic i agree i made a video on
morgot a couple months ago
that yeah he's a very tragic character
everyone give the the person to your
left and chat a hug everyone give each
other a hug
debuff your health it's okay
we will get that debuff gone we just
need a hug right now
hug your neighbor peace love
peace and love
you are
i will take you in my arms as often as
okay
i will take you in my arms as often as
it takes
hug
is there a hack to speed up the
animation of getting a hug
do ronda's
roger roger here
what a blessing would you like
give me another hug
you never have happy quest endings why
is this your is this your first from
software game
you are so
i
despite all so please
my dear go fight ocelot
in dark souls 3.
the dude slams an invisible baby into
the ground a certain person gave it to
me
so did she just eat it on the floor what
the hell
where are their shadows probably in dlc
you mean the shadows for the other
empyreans
melania and mikala
that is a good question we do not know
who is your favorite npc
it's it's a tie between millicent and
alexander i don't believe we've met
millicent has an amazing story
i honed down those who live in death
heed those who live in death they can
still do raj
unless you wish to
well well
with a prowess for we
i do like blight as well
i do
i don't want an introduction
no well no sense
what now
very well sure
it will lead
i'm just trying to give you something my
guy the map indicates what will lead you
to
well
what have we here how did you get your
hands on that dagger
well i know why don't i you guys know
what i did the other day
i killed
mill not millicent i killed muriel
don't do it
it's
tragic
i don't know if anyone's ever done that
i may have been the first person ever to
kill muriel
i just wanted to see what would happen
don't do it
it is truly a gasp
where are my dog boys at
i know i'm a i'm a monster
oh wait i thought we could do it here
maybe i was wrong
maybe he doesn't show up here now
ooh
that's good to know
i think we already effed it up earlier
despite
the way that i'm going through the world
like some quest lines just get
completely heated off if you don't do
a certain thing
in a certain order because obviously i'm
lying around all over the place
guys i'm a researcher of this game i
needed to see what would happen if i
killed muriel okay
i did it
it was awful and i hated it
do you want to see
you're tarnished aren't you
i welcome you to the church of vows
steward of this sacred chamber
my apologies for the unseemly state of
affairs oh we've killed patches
how it came to be known as the church of
vows
he does say something weird where
he uh he says he can't die
well that is a shame
but who can blame you
the shattering has caused us
all of us
to lose sight of something very dear
it is here at the church i just like
listening
hmm
he lives in all our hearts can i just
show you that dialogue like i think if i
hit him once he says it
okay hold on i have an idea
i won't let you guys see it
just listen
please oh god my flesh is akin to stone
akin to stone
i cannot be wounded
i cannot die
okay or will i cause any harm unto you
cease your futile efforts
okay i'm sorry there you go there's the
dialogue all right
for research
i'm leaving
i never hit him i don't know what you
guys are talking about
but i've never heard that before
no victory for the golden nor for the
moon no prize but atonement the birth of
a vow
shut up goat
but i would never never show that on
screen it's it'd just make me a monster
how do you sleep at night i don't
all right now what where do we go
i wonder why he says that he can't die
because i promise you
he does
he dies
and he screams like in terror it's
really bad
what about the less known lore like the
clayman their spell descriptions are
quite interesting
the clayman
who the hell is who are the claiming
it is exact he screams like you step on
a lego
they're the enemies in the knox stella
that's what they're called they're
called the clayman
okay
i did lie i do sleep really good
i have a watch that tells me how fast i
fall asleep and how well i sleep
i can fall asleep and the fastest i've
ever fallen asleep like being a wide
awake to just being dead asleep was 45
seconds
at least from what my watch tells me
they are the remains of the priests
of the old underground dynasties
they still search lost oracles within
their bubbles
that is interesting
yep
metal babe in the chat calls me an old
man because i go to bed at like 9 00 p.m
and i wake up at like five in the
morning
[Music]
is there a church back here did i see
that
yep everyone call me old
get it out of your system
i am old i really am
oh
ball
[Music]
ball for ball
why is it here though
oh it's probably weak to magic huh
vanquishing enemy groups
that's fine
we don't need that
guys how old do you think i am
be honest
that bear has as much health as malakath
like what
120
31
34
42
do i seem that old
late 20s early 30s
there
you sound around 30
okay
90 years old you know how old i am you
forehead
i said be honest
it ain't nothing but a number
i agree
okay that's just a bunch of numbers
i'm 27.
all right
i i was old to the rocket league
community okay i didn't think i was old
to you guys
27 five months
go look at the pillars before the
ancestral spirit fight they were very
interesting
okay like the
[Music]
see i don't think i'm old either but i
act old
like going to bed at 9 00 p.m and waking
up at five in the morning
is that normal for a 27 year old
i don't know
you talking about these pillars or these
ones
right here
because they look the same
we got hieroglyphics on these things huh
okay
okay
what the [ __ ] is that
my initial reaction is are they
depicting pharah missoula
because it kind of looks like all those
dudes in those coffins in pharah
missoula they get out of them
they're like doing some type of like
coffin thing right here
something to do with like out in the
woods those look like trees
and then this looks like a tornado kind
of to me
could be wrong though
they're in mogwin's palace
up there
okay
are these just the same
yeah they are
what's going on out here
what are these
it looks like boats sailing poorly
are these
like their own trees
this reminds me of the elden beast fight
like these
uh whoa i don't know what i just did
these columns
they look like trees
let's just go look at that let me go
beat up radagon really quick
there were torches read ghost flame
torch description but i don't think it's
representing them
i don't know how they would
frost has got to be the strongest thing
in this game i don't even think bleeds
the strongest
could just be stones
yeah but why are they why are there so
many of them
as well
but they look like this
out here
and do we have a lot of viewers or
something like usually when you have
more viewers you get more bots
i never know how many people are here
hold up fam
they gone
don't they look similar
like kinda
can't say for sure
similar sky
oh yeah i played uh
i play a lot of golf
a lot
i don't think they look that similar
actually it just reminded me of it
you guys ever said seen the okay so look
at this look at this
and then um
i always spell this wrong
let me do this bloodborne vinyl
god
not definition
seen the outside of uh
it's not really a good picture
i guess this one's pretty okay
back here in bloodborne you see this
these columns
let me look up a video
look at that look at that back there
very similar huh
there we go look at that
no i don't do any pvp
i'm trying to get a good
visual but you get what i'm saying
god bloodborne's so freaking cool dude
anyway
i have titleist ap3 irons
i'm thinking of getting a new set though
bestowed ost in uh all of all of the
games man it's the best
bloodborne
or gearman
everything in soulsborne games is a
berserk reference
did i watch berserk
i haven't even seen it yet
the crucible is the formless mother
because of their connection uh to the
omens
maybe
it's potential
don't watch it read it
yeah
but that means i have to read
you know
sorry sorry sorry
the anime is on youtube
i already read enough for this game
you know
that's it we're reading berserk
hmm
all right what else should we look at
no anime adaptation fully adapted the
manga but the 90s one is the most
complete one
which charred corpses where are those
they're in the dark souls one intro
really
trying to think
dark souls one intro
hmm those are all trees
it's the the other thing we can say
about that though is that all of these
games are made by the same people
so it doesn't mean that they're
connected but they just use the same
like
types of stuff i don't i don't know how
to put it
you know what i'm saying
[Music]
obelisk represented people growing trees
pretty shot
there we go
what do the trees mean
i think they mean
different dimensions
of the same thing we all have our own
tree
like this tree is mine you all have your
own you're in a different dimension
because you play through the game as a
tarnish seeking the seeking the throne
in your own way
right
by the way i think this is the best
armor set that you can get in the game
it's sick
radon gauntlets and
leggings
champions
helmet
champions altered
it's my favorite
who do you think the storm lord was
i don't know
malchest armor
a little tight a little tight
laura's all over the place but damn i
love this game
uh i mean i i said that in a previous
video where i think the lore in this
game is purposely purposefully
misleading
it constantly tries to throw you off
track with other things
and confuse you about absolutely
everything
uh
but
that's just kind of how it is
storm lord's a dead thing under
stormville castle no
[Music]
that is a growing
infestation of godwin i believe right
let's go see
like one of his uh
[Music]
like shedding skin
like a growth of him
[Music]
ow we
what
it's like a yeah it's just more of god
one
like is he's growing
everywhere
what the [ __ ]
oh my god why did it spawn so late jesus
christ that scared me i thought this
thing came to life
prince of des postel let's read that
where's where
where
[ __ ] where
did i pass it
dude why did it come out so late it
scared the [ __ ] out of me
oh it's a talisman
that's right
we have three okay we have two
it is said that this puzzle
came from the visage of the prince of
death
who used to be called godwin
at first dead of the demi as first dead
of the demigods it said he
he's buried deep under the capital at
the erd trees roots also
it's saying that he's the first of the
dead demigods
are is it just like him and ronnie or
were there more
so what does this one say
it is said that this cyst came from the
corrupted visage of of one unable to die
a true death
indeed it comes from the prince of death
scion of the golden bow as the first of
the dead among the demigods
so those bodies in the mausoleums are
other demigods
like they're actually demigods
where is one
that we can go to let's just go to the
one in
here yeah
it's like a tree branch
that's why we can double the
remembrances
right
but we can double a remembrance of any
demigod at any mausoleum right
it's not specific
not any any demigod
you can't
i haven't done enough times to know it
what
you actually can
alright
i'm going right through that bro
are we already falling yes
okay
i needed some milk
not all remembrances
so if i wanted to duplicate
the ancestral spirit will it let me do
it
okay i got
more got
i guess that's the only one i've
technically killed
even though i have
uh everybody's
99 times over
the non-build mausoleums can't duplicate
shard bears
to my understanding the bell
is
it's of co it's the only thing the only
reason that the bell is chiming
is as
it's like an alarm or something right
it's like
mourning
the dead
right to everybody
i'm not sure
hi jake i do you have a law based theory
why some enemies disappear in a cloud of
lights when dying while others leave a
dead body behind
and do you have a law based theory why
some enemies respawn while others do not
thank you for the
20 euros rg i really appreciate that
do you have a lore based theory why some
enemies disappear in a cloud of lights
when dying
while others leave a dead body behind
it's
how do i explain that it's um
yeah some of them actually don't respawn
it has so the people that disappear in a
ray of light kinda like kind of dusty
light i think is they're
being
doesn't mean they're being returned to
the urgery
but then they're just like put back when
we
respawn
it's like people the people who
disappear like that are of grace
and then those who
just die
are
never had it
the ones that are touched by grace i'm
pretty sure that's right
it's tough to answer that question
because there's so many different
enemies but i really appreciate the
super chat thank you
yeah it's like when you kill margaret
and it's really not even morgot it's
just like a projection of him
yeah it's so like they're also like
they respond just like we do because
we've been touched by the side of grace
and that's the reason we can just come
back to life is because we're constantly
being called back by
grace right
whereas others are just like here from
the beginning it's like when we kill a
crucible knight they've never been
touched by the side of grace so when you
kill them they're dead they don't come
back
hopefully that answers your question and
thank you again i really appreciate that
yes to my understanding these right here
are demigods
i think queen america had a lot more
kids than
the ones that we have
i mean think about the royal omens in
the sewers
why does this look all milky
that's another yeah we don't know enough
about godwin to know how many kids he
had
sorry it's [ __ ] water
i apologize
boom lake
the [ __ ] water
look at that [ __ ] water
it's like a ride in a coffin
is there anything in here
nope this has something to do with uh
gravity magic
something
because when we rest in it we see uh
like these runes
that are like the same sketchings as on
radon swords
actually does this one just fall
i think this one doesn't use gravity
magic
what a great example
the mausoleums are a part of godwin
yes
oh hi robert how many hours are you up
to a lot way too many i play this game
non-stop all the time
look at my dumb ass face
hey
i had to take a break from this game for
a little while i was getting really
frustrated with this game
what indian did you pick on your first
playthrough uh i just did elden lord i
wanted to be elden lord
yeah i don't have 7 500 hours
not yet
let me find the other one where's the
other uh
often
it is
wait
let me get my bearings let me get my
bearings here here
right there
don't
make me fight
the two okay
stay over there
i can't use it dang it all right we
gotta beat him
these guys are weak to frost
stop waddling around
nice
excellent
yeah i think it's more i have 99
in everything that definitely helps us a
lot
wait
i agree we're splashing again
terrible
any fister builders
i haven't done a fist build yet now
all right but check this out there's
definitely some runes going on here
you have any advice for someone going to
play dark souls 3 after eldering
have fun elden ring is very much based
off of dark souls 3. it's going to be
great you're going to love it
the bosses are so so much slower in dark
souls 3. you're gonna think it's easy i
would think
look at all those runes right there
a lot of ruinage
wait can i pause
whoa that was tripping me out what the
i could pause the background but not the
coffin
i love bots
go away
[Music]
thank you metal
do you read the brick hammer description
it mentions a revolution and a hero
okay but we saw the ruins there right
now we're gonna go to radon
can't slow down progress
i don't think color has a lot to do with
gravity magic
where are your swords radon
oh you're on your back
whoop that is pausing okay
yeah kinda rooney
why are we getting so many bots today
holy crap
thank you again
can't see him very well take him out
leonard
okay sorry leonard
um
i mean how else would you describe the
the gravity magic of the the coffin
rising into the sky it's not gravity
magic
molina espouses that her mother resides
within the earth tree reasonably you
would assume that she is america's
lineage do you think that the father is
radigan godfrey do you think that molina
could be the glomide queen
i am 99 sure and thank you very much for
the super chat peter
i'm 90 i'm always 99 percent sure about
anything because i don't think you can
be 100 sure of anything in this game
um melania is the glomide queen like i
think i might be 100 on that
melano does not have a mother or a
father she even has dialogue
that she doesn't know what it's like to
have a mother or a father
or to have a parent
um
she asks about bach and that's how that
comes up we could try and get that
actually
um
i believe that melania is just a
fragment of america which
would be like
pinkish hair
because america is ratagon radagon has
red hair america has blonde hair
she created a fragment of herself to
help us on our journey
melania's just like she's not even real
like she's not a person
i think she was used as like what the
glomite queen was used for by queen
america
um before the shattering of everything
as well
so i don't think she's a daughter
of anything she
when she says the mother inside the
urgery she
references her mother inside the archery
which is queen america
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
that's her actual mom
we
trippy
it's hard to explain
i don't think leonard has an hp bar i
don't think so either
nope
how you doing leonard
is he heavy
yeah i don't think you can say like the
coffins don't have gravity magic because
it's not purple
i don't know about that one
was melanin furion i don't think she's
anything she she has she exists to
burn the her tree that's literally the
only reason she's alive
or to stop us
if we um decide to become the lord of
chaos
oh um what
hammer were you talking about lorenzo
because we can read that
brick
is it just hammer
what up ludwig
brick hammer
so it's brick hammer
weapon made from an ordinary stone brick
wielded by a laborer of who led a
rebellion
and later became a champion himself
even among other blungeons of its size
this weapon is especially weighty
the strength of a giant is required to
wield it
barbaric roar
this has to mean
this has to mean godfrey right
oh great hammer
that has to mean godfrey
giant crusher
i don't know how we're getting a bigger
hammer than that
i know he doesn't use a hammer but we
don't know what weapons he used before
everything
that whole description sounds exactly
like uh
godfrey
i think she has the same move set as the
black knives because she is a fragment
of melano who is
newman and all of the black knight
assassins are newman as well
okay giant crusher hammer made from a
boulder used in the war against the
giants
against the giants one of the heftiest
weapons in the entire lands between
after the giants were quelled a man
turned against
and man turned against man in violence
this weapon was all but forgotten man
has grown feeble in comparison to its
forebears
a man turned against man and violence
read the ripple axe description
ripple axe
i don't know what the ripple axe looks
like so i'm just looking at things that
look like an axe
ripple axe blade
unique weapon wielded by young alvin
oryx this sword is moderate modeled
after the ripples
that are thought to be the origin of
their species
the ripples that are thought to be the
origin of their species
what does that mean
is that a weapon lorenzo or am i looking
at the moon
hey that would make sense like uh
the albanorics are made of like stone
like maybe from the moon they could be
from the moon
loretta's shield
just look at the moon
oh
uh let's just go to the moonlight altar
that's where we definitely get the best
view of the moon
give us moon
that's one of the moons
there's the other moon behind a [ __ ]
tree
why
yeah when i hear the word ripples i
think of water
also peter thank you again for that
super chat i don't think i said that
enough thank you very much
i can't really tell i really can't
didn't they delete the other moon nope
it's right there
it's definitely right there
my understanding there's like
legitimately two moons
you're at a shield
okey-dokey
okay there we go
loretta's shield what does that look
like
the kaku
what does loretta shield look like i
actually don't know
two moons no sun yeah the sun's really
not that important in this
ronald's dump truck of an ass
how many shields are in this game my guy
holy crap
it's a mirror shield
god
just don't remember what it looks like
black leather blue crust
your shield inverted hawk beast is this
called loretta's shield
right before the great shields
oh is it this one
wait this actually looks like it is it
this
yep
shield of radiant silver
what the [ __ ] is festooned
with amber and carried by loretta knight
of the halek tree
the shape is said to imitate that of a
sacred drop of dew
which inspired the absurd rumor that
loretta herself was an albanork
absurd rumor
decorated okay
some some words they use in this game
are just redonkulous
what is on top of me oh it's a deer what
the [ __ ]
okay
she has red blood
let's go look
doesn't everyone have red blood
she is there to protect the albanorics
but i guess it just was made a rumor
that she is one
where
she wait why is the fog gate here what
wait she's right here but i can't move
you can hear the horse
i just have to come in this way
i see
there we go
welcome loretta
welcome
okay let me fix the sun so we can
actually see oops
that looks fine
loretta calm down
come here
pause
all right
it looks like she's just gonna run
around
you're a literal horse in here
okay
kinda looks like a silver tier
hello are you here
you have eyes or anything
no eyes or mouth
is the cool stuff you get with pc gaming
hmm
are we the number one friend of the
albanorks
and know about that
i don't think we can learn anything just
from like looking at her like this
this haley tree armor yeah oh runes look
at that
yeah those are like kind of the cipher
runes on the outside of the helmet
hmm
i'm just gonna keep running around
slow down
look at the runes again
if you guys think you can read those
here i'll just position it like this
you guys can translate this
it's ancient norse
on the shield
i don't see anything on the shield
can't read them though okay
those are the second real-life runes
that we see on eldon ring
i mean do you think they just use them
like
the developers just use them for like
i don't know
filler
what about the runes on random platforms
that make you descend from certain
places
so
hold on
i have to exit out of the fight
i don't want to kill any boss in case we
want to come back
yeah like are they just using it because
it looks cool or is it like actually
mean something i really doubt it
what the
what
what
[Music]
acquire information about death
forgot what that was like all right uh
let me just think of a place so we go
[Music]
let's just go here
like the elevators you're talking about
right
let's see if those runes are the same
we do need to go look at that statue
because i'm pretty sure it's america
uh mykola and melania
like a statue of those three
ah
welcome
whoops i went too low
dang it
bollocks
you calm down sir
the runes and caleb
where are the runes in caled i'm going
to look at these for something
for my own
personal
research
i should be able to ride him
all right
definitely not runes got it okay
where where in caled are their runes
shut up millson
teleport the grave with a merchant
at the start of lorena
that's not anywhere near caled what
with a merchant
oh here
definitely runes
are those the same letters as on the
the helmet of loretta
i'll just put it here this seems to fill
it out pretty good
not norse
the [ __ ]
it's simplified hebrew
so they're just using assets from real
world real world things that just have
them here
interesting
anybody confirm that this is hebrew
or is it just a look like hebrew
oh aren't there um
there are lots of columns in the bed
chamber
[Music]
has ever noticed this
all of
these of tablets
that looks like gibberish scribble
gibberish
hmm
what's up here
where's this light come from
oh
excellent
holy bots what is happening today
eminently i've never had this many bots
dude
okay some light reading okay the bots
are dead they're dead oops
look at all these tablets in this room
the stacks of them this is america's
room right oh
hello
what's that look like boys anything
can't tell if i'm upside down or not
i mean it kind of looks like there's
something going on there
yeah there's scrolls
does that bed not look obnoxiously
uncomfortable
it's made of stone
with one cloth on it
it's a nice room but [ __ ]
hello
little flower patterns underneath
looks very uncomfortable also is this
is she this tall
i don't think she's even that big
right
i mean the room is called queen's
bedchamber so i'm assuming this is her
bed
there are some names that have meaning
in latin jaima means blood
is there a character in the game named
haima
medallion on the floor
there's a medallion on the floor
i'm a glintstone and crown
i'm from what i'm getting from us
talking about this
it just seems like from software used
like latin
jewish jewish norse to just kind of
fill it with
things
you know what i mean like let's say they
use the word hyma maybe it really
doesn't mean anything like maybe it's
just a word
that they use for it you know what i'm
saying like
we could be putting ourselves in a in a
hole here
thinking about this stuff
which is really hard not to do in this
game by the way
gotta think about everything
so now we got
godfrey
who if i if i put the camera inside of
this he's not actually holding morgot
yet
has his hands out
yeah his axe is definitely chipped and
broken
i wonder if we can find this half
of his axe
inside
or on one of the enemies in the game
like on the dragon lord or
[Music]
the fire giant maybe
is morgot even in here yet
no i know he's holding the sun but i
just thought it was funny that he's not
actually holding anything here yet
snowfield map description or metal
alisman's info
is maps not info
where can i read like the maps
they're key items
those are all cookbooks
not seeing it not seeing it oh i may
actually not have them i just thought of
that
well yes i do
i just looked at info and they were not
there
you're trying to find all this [ __ ] my
god
where the paintings are
i mean i just don't see the maps am i
just going right by them
yeah we have the remembrance of the lich
dragon
let me look at the metal like the rolled
like medallion is that what you're
talking about
why am i am i [ __ ] blind dude
oh there it is
brandish the medallion activates the
grand lift of rolled concealing the
mountains of giants the forge of the
flame of ruin is said to be found upon
their peak
it is is here melano wishes to travel in
resuming your journey together i don't
know what that tells us at all
okay
reveals a hidden study hall she connects
do you want to be able to secretly fix
the pedestal celestial globe okay
ground and sky inverted
i don't think we're gonna get anything
there
i don't know if we can see the maps
can you pick a moral or theme from elden
ring
in dark souls it feels like the moral is
to let go
in bloodborne it feels like the moral is
to not seek secrets
but i can't pick one for eldon ring
a moral huh
i think if i were to pick one for elden
ring
and
i guess press one in chat if you agree
with me
and press two if you don't if i had to
pick one for this game it would be
what you see is not always what it is
that would be mine like that's what i
would pick
i'm banning i got him
okay i think they're gone
what you see is not always what it is
that would be mine
that's what i think
because like we're we're told through
the whole game like the golden order is
like this great amazing thing when it's
really not
never judge a book by its cover that's
another good way to put it yeah
it's a bit vague hey the entire game's
vague my guy
the entire game is vague as [ __ ]
they've never been this vague in my
opinion i feel like dark souls wasn't as
vague as this bloodborne wasn't nearly
as vague as this sakira is very
straightforward compared to this
like god damn
this game is vegas
[ __ ]
gods are bad and feet are good
i like it
i like it
no couldn't couldn't be vague
oh the
guy's gone i have to get out of here
actually
i don't want to do too much where the
the world is now permanently
tree there we go
maybe it's that you're stronger than you
think somebody in chat said it earlier
that
we could be mikala
which
i actually really like that
that'd be a tough sell though
stagnation equals bad
i like that one too
seems like the america's entire plan is
to invoke change
is there explanation for the
descriptions
uh
no
another thing
is that what we read in the descriptions
may not be true
as well
i think somebody had a theory that
one person or the painter wrote all the
descriptions
which
that would just make everything
confusing
yeah
that would just be a ridiculously tough
sell to say that we are mikola
which we are talking about are uh
my theory earlier that the guy in the
cocoon is not mikola which that was like
an hour and a half ago at this point
but
all i can say right now is i'm not sold
on this guy in the cocoon bean mikala
definitively
even though moog says dearest mikalov
he could be just talking up to the blood
and not the body
wake up i need answers
wake up right now
wake up
gideon says it's mikula and he wouldn't
lie no gideon would never lie guys
gideon's never lied to us before
that slithery snake
yes i think the pelvic bone we talked
about this earlier i know a lot of new
people are here now but this pelvic bone
that he's placed on definitely looks
like uh what's up here
i think the entire tree the entire
halogen tree is mykola
or
he uses his blood
to spread him all over the place but it
came from here which i'm assuming the
pelvic bone came from here as well it's
like if we look at this like let's say
this isn't mikala for a second and this
is just like
the mother
like think of the mother like it clearly
looks like a body here and this is where
the pelvic bone would be like someone
who's pregnant here right
dude these plots are [ __ ] insane holy
[ __ ]
god
let's have every different variation of
a different name it's insane
he is the all-knowing after all
can we see the top branches i don't know
what you mean by that
what do you mean by top branches
oh my god
when you defeat the elden beast it says
god slain which suggests it is very much
very much is the greater will that
doesn't mean it's the greater will
i think it's a manifestation of the
greater will
master chef what master chief
sorry my sister is texting me
what were those videos we watched
together the toy story thing and
something
oh um
good master chief
guys what's the alien called in um
in halo like those purple dudes
are being chief thank you
that's what she wants she me and my
sister used to used to watch that when
we were kids and we loved it
yeah the arbiters
arby and chief thank you very much
yup
yup yup thank you
that's awesome
you guys knew exactly what i was talking
about
ew maddie's going to work
ew
you think the greater will is america
what are the statues before the divine
towers representing
who are the statues before the divine
towers representing
you mean just all of them
i'm from indonesia hi
i'm from america
reichard's knights they don't have much
war
the uh the crucible
crucible dudes
let me go to one of these bridges
empty arenas
um
there's just big spaces in this game
it's a big game
nice to meet you too
yeah do we know who this is
that's a good question
looks like a man to me
just
physically
it's a big sword
dude i have to i have to poop
i really do
kinda looks like ratagon
all right i got you guys
i actually have to go to the bathroom
but i will be back
uh what do you guys want to watch while
i'm gone it might be five minutes
i'll be gone five eight minutes max
if i were smart i put on one of my own
youtube videos but that's kind of dumb
as well
what do i got here
there's a hundred and sixty people in
here nice
that's cool thank you
ten hours of michael
jordan noises michael jackson
if with what would i put on
what is this elden ring finishing view
quest before committing the cardinal sin
and it's courage the cowardly dog
the heck
oh god
where do you see charlie
oh i'll put on moist there you go
this week is perhaps one of the most
important moments of my life second only
to the day i was birthed and breastfed i
am talking about the rlcs world
championship nope we don't talk about
rocket league on this channel anymore
absolutely not
i refuse i'm putting on one of my videos
i can't think of anything else i can't
can't even think
you also get some background noise
here you go
i have to poop man i have to go
can you hear me
hello all right i'll be right back
can you hear me
help me i'm stuck
hello
hello
anyone
iron fist alexander a living jar who has
set out on a journey away from his
comfortable hidden away home of jarburg
to venture the world and become a mighty
warrior living jars are brought to life
by human flesh and blood they are rather
kinley folk which just means that
they're warm-hearted and gentle in
nature their description says that they
were perhaps made to be better than
their innards their fragments command a
high price due to their magical power
locked within this leaves the living
jars unfortunate targets for poachers we
can learn more about these poachers from
our little pot boy jar barn do you know
what a poacher is cuz
they hunt us
smash us
and then take us away
this village is kept secret
so
i think we're safe here
but you should be careful if you ever
meet one of them cause
i hope uncle alexander beats them all up
first
these poachers are the perfumers that we
can see spread around the lands between
in times past the role of a perfumer was
much respected a blessed role in the
eyes of the many but after entering the
battlefields of the shattering they
performed no such role creating their
aromatics for poisons and explosives
eventually they became deprived and used
their own spices and potions to alter
their own body and mind they seem to
want the power of the shards of magic
within the living jars and have started
a slow descent into their own
self-destruction another being that
seems to hunt down the living jars are
the urgery avatars that we can see
surrounded by smash jars under many of
the minor herb trees the staff that they
wield tells us that the avatars emerged
in the wake of the elden ring shattering
and were determined to protect the
withering herd tree's offspring they
likely smashed these living jars that
are filled with the flesh of the many of
fallen warriors who need to be returned
to the earth tree which helps feed the
minor urgeries and helps keep them from
dying however some of these jars decide
to fight back against these poachers
just like alexander who wants to become
a great warrior alexander intends to
take part in the radon festival to fight
against a legendary demigod to further
test his abilities in battle before he
leaves he rewards you with exalted flesh
for helping him out of this peculiar
random hole that he was stuck in exalted
flesh is considered a delicacy in the
badlands an invigorating meal that was
for the exclusive benefit of those who
they deem as heroes i believe this
reward that he actually gives us more
than once tells us more of what
alexander truly wants to be he wants to
be like us a tarnished warrior he has
the flesh of the fallen within his jar
and the flesh of those who once had the
sight of grace which is why i believe we
could find alexander in these holes
usually the sights of grace and the
sending gates are only meant for the
tarnished or those who still have or
once had the sight of grace within them
so it is possible that he has the
ability to travel as we do however since
it's just the flesh of grace mixed
randomly within his jar it obviously
doesn't go well every time he tries to
teleport and i'm sorry i just have to
say this but i have a hard time
believing that from software didn't
purposely make his dialogue somewhat
suggestive at times i'm back how's the
video gosh
stop please
that's my face this will have me as
slippery as a toad give me a good smack
from behind with something nice and big
oh yes
oh yes all right if you guys want to
watch the rest you have to go you have
to go watch
if you haven't already
if you haven't go watch it again
i'm back
no leave it on nope gotta go watch it
dude this guy put on he's horrible i
know
i know
i know
you started this you gotta see it
through
clearly i don't
out of all the story characters who
would you bang
nobody dude can you imagine the diseases
that are flying around this world bro
absolutely nobody
it's terrifying
is it
is it terrifying yeah
me
huh
am i scaring you
okay
okay
you know why some of these are just like
i guess they just got knocked off by
something
looks like a happy radon kind of does
actually
old man surrounded by flowers across the
roads in altus and lining the interior
of the round table hold
statues of the old man surrounded by
flowers
where is that
across the roads isn't that a
is that what like an area is called
never mind i'm wrong
along the road
yes it's just called highway junction
[Music]
bellum highway
this is bellum highway
right
no this is bellum highway
right
near the church where you see hyena
melon highway
this
hmm
that's like a scar
hmm
it's kind of holding it like a sword and
these look like tree branches obviously
damn those lips are puckered dude do you
see that
it's like he's trying to make out with
the sky
freak
interesting
the rod god
could be mikala
maybe
press one in chat if we need dlc like
right now
it doesn't look like a kid
but then again people think the dude the
cocoon is michelle of but they're like
that doesn't look like anything like a
kid
hey moe do you know candace
can this dick fit in your mouth oh my
god oh my [ __ ]
is this like multiple
no it's just because i haven't touched
it yet
holy [ __ ] i've been live for three hours
it's lit out here kuh
i think this is just radagon up here
well
they're the same person so yeah
he's got that grid texture behind him
wait a minute
wow that looks like i'm zooming in on
his dick no i'm looking at these
do these not look like the omen's skin
they kind of do
it's his hair
look at that it's coming off of his hair
[Music]
in forming this
it's clearly got golden hair here but
it's yeah it's rattagon
i mean you could just tell by this that
ratagon's america if you knew who
ratagon was at this point in the game if
you were here
look like knots i'm talking the texture
like right here
you see that
kind of this this texture
kind of looks like
nicolas skin
or
who we are now i'm just going to say
whoever's in this cocoon because i don't
think it's mickela
get out of the way mo
shut up
this skin right here
it's kind of dotty
you know
i don't know how to describe it
bro these
and bots today are unreal
i've never had this many bots it's
insane
holy i got disoriented
you guys find a girlfriend from the bot
do you see what i mean like this right
here
it kind of
just looks like there's dots in them
right here
thank you doomguy
it's kinda not exactly
wake up
i need you to wake up
can't even hit him
interesting
hmm
it's kind of thinking right now
yeah is does he like the who's this like
does he like the formless mother i i
swear i saw this in like the
the lake of rot
right
is this not the guy in the lake of rot
where the [ __ ] is this hello oh never
mind
hmm
the lake of thought
why would he be in the lake of rot
though
yeah let me show the like a rot one
maybe i'm wrong like it could just look
similar
let's go here
right it could just be an area where
this guy is right
definitely the same
definitely
thousand percent
these guys are all worshipping him but
they they like took over this area it's
not doesn't mean that this was
this could have been here way before
they all just took it over you know
i see a couple of legs right there
that's definitely a couple of weird legs
i wouldn't mind any dlc lorenzo i ain't
gonna cap with you my guy anything would
be great
i take dlc
yeah about anything
they're praying to him
give me a hug chat
and give me a hug
excellent
hmm
you know nothing jon ooh
i love how when you're not looking at
characters they walk around like this
like when you're not looking directly at
characters that's how they move
and then there's a big one out here
right
do you ever wish you could have
experienced this game without
the push to make content for it
yes
the answer to that is yes
but here we are
yep it's all the same statues
which you know this area is just clearly
taken over by the rot doesn't mean it
was always here and then they were like
made these while this was here you know
looks like he's just holding a slab
of some kind
okay
[Music]
kind of like the slabs that are
inside of some giants like eg
markings on those statues
i'm gone
they kind of look like these
not exactly though
return the slab
return the slab
who knows what that's from
you had a good childhood if you do
let's see look at his eyes
yep that's courage the cowardly dog
uh-huh
absolutely i don't think they look
exactly the same that did not
yeah i would say that they're not the
same
type of slab
return
the slap look at the dog's plane out
there i've dude i've played this game
way too much over the past
how long has this game been out
came out february like late february
let's call it march
april
may
june july it's been over five months
and my my entire year has turned into
this game
and i love it
we got a thick old booty
trying to think of what else we could
just come back to this next stream
i think we're just kind of all over the
place
so you guys notice that the stars don't
move
because they're actually not moving
because of radon
like when you just look up in the sky
like this
they're kind of just twinkling right
they actually look like the blue stars
out here
actually look like they're trying to
move but they're not
you see that
i wonder if we kill radon
do the stars kind of move again
like does the sky move because that
would be sick
should we test it
go kill him in two seconds
god
damn
there's so many accounts
they stay motionless
doing a little test here and i think
we'll conclude the stream there and i
also really like this cutscene so we're
gonna watch it
you're killing him wrong
why the hell is the sun there what
the sun is so [ __ ] in this game
boom
[Music]
that cutscene's just so cool
did they add the sun i don't remember
what the sky just changed
it's probably because i'm using hacks
that's why it's doing that
alexander
hey buddy
what are you playing
see
i see it now
humans all lose their will how could
this
was my whole existence just
a crop
yes
clearly
why
why not all right let's go back to the
same spot
i just like making chat mad
it's my job
all right let's look at the stars
theory
rushed
they still do the same thing
wouldn't that be cool though
would that not be cool
if
the stars started to move in the sky
again once you kill radon
myth busted
yep that would be cool though
it would be cool
oh don't tell me you guys haven't beaten
alexander one time
like in your second playthrough you just
went up to him and killed him for his
shard
we
never
it's an oversight
this from software usually
oversight things
do they you know does that happen
from time to time
still don't have the shard
killed him in pharah missoula but not in
cold blood you monster
i'm sorry
he dies a tragic death no matter what
why do the stars even move
oh damn
should we kill eg now just kidding
i would never be
that crazy
all right chat
i think that's gonna do it for today
i might stream tomorrow
we'll see
but
maybe not
i have no idea but we talked about a lot
of stuff today a lot
my plan
for these streams is to kind of do what
we did today just kind of talk with chad
about everything and discuss stuff um
i'm thinking about
editing them down into videos for my
second channel
it's called more agt jake i haven't made
any videos on there yet if you're
interested in that
you can go down into the description i
think it's one of the top things it'll
say second channel it's just called more
agt jake if you're not don't worry about
it but
you can always just rewatch these
streams if you want but if you want i'm
thinking about editing them down into
something for a second channel i've been
trying to start a second channel for a
while but don't know how
so
the main channel is mainly just for like
lore stuff and then like whatever kind
of comes along like these streams
obviously
um
but
we'll see we'll see how that turns out
because i'm not sure
but
appreciate everyone being here we
actually had a lot more people here than
i i thought we would so i really
appreciate that i hadn't streamed in
like a month
um
so it was fun to come back i always love
streaming on youtube it's been super fun
so thank you everybody for being here
appreciate you very much um
and i might be back tomorrow or the next
day next week i'm actually gonna be in
la
i'm gonna be in los angeles visiting a
friend and just kind of exploring la
because i've never been there
um
i'm also planning on moving
maybe not super soon but
somewhere i don't know yet
a lot of life stuff going on right now
so we will see but i'll try and stream
as much as i can and get content out to
you guys as much as i can as well so
thank you for all the support check the
description for all kinds of stuff that
you might be interested in up to you
and we will be back
definitely again this week so
appreciate you guys have a great rest of
your day thanks for being here
and i'll see you all
again very soon
peace and love bros bye bye bye